so I have another thing that I'm
concerned about I'm gonna just read you
something okay no don't do that don't
publish this first so the other last
week ago Bobby it's joke or just Bobby
if there's personal [ __ ] I don't know
I'm gonna read the whole thing
I will just read us Bobby is joke or
I'll edit this out if you don't want it
no you won't yeah I sort of got it well
you don't even have a proper surrounding
it's and real I said I feel like when I
go I said are you okay and you go we're
better now are you really concerned yeah
jerk how are you that's [ __ ] rude
well you are a piece of [ __ ] no you are
my face you want to see concerned you
want to see my shirt I'm gonna I'm gonna
do this okay
answer go see you're joking around again
leave it right there
that was good come on let me do it again
one more time I swear to God your
concern looks like you're holding your
own shot yeah let me try all right I'm
with are you okay right yeah that's why
I asked you are you concerned I don't
are you okay no no no yeah who says do
stuttering to make you something concern
though I'm concerned we don't have to
get into what you're going through by
missing I was concerned and that's the
past you know thank you
yeah I really appreciate you going
through a tough time yeah yeah but she
is healthy your wife yeah your
girlfriend you guys get married soon
you're gonna get married she's got I did
you meet her she just came out I mean
all of a sudden she's the thing you know
what happened he's been around for a
long time I know a couple years all
right no well now yeah but she's been in
my life for about 12 years
Wow yeah I didn't know that yeah yeah
how a back and forth off and on just two
stupid people that's all it was yeah we
finally realized ah yeah yeah we really
what was she living she was uh in a cave
how much money yeah and then I say
machine la that was you know she yeah
I'm joking by the way she was in LA yeah
she had a great yeah she yes she's cute
you guys look good together
it's like you and your lady yeah yeah I
mean more so your lady but like well
you're a cute couple hey being sponsored
by Hawaiian raw what the [ __ ] does that
mean on your [ __ ] plump body right
now do you want the real answer yeah yes
so what the whole space mayor Tom
Selleck you still have that arm shabu
shabu restaurant yes where is that in
Vegas in Vegas and you're more than
welcome
is it good after she loves shopping
shabu is a good duh yes it's amazing
Bobby yeah what do you have any slice
dog my god what's in there oh that's fun
is it good are you going for the easy up
co-venture different Yoko Kobe yeah yo
probably meat in there yes I have that's
that's generic that's nothing compared
to what I have oh really what do you
have I have Wagyu oh yeah Wagyu oh yeah
yeah I have mammoth meat of mine
where's your restaurant right where's
your restaurant it's in [ __ ] Beverly
Hills right now today mammoth meat and
can you find mammoth bro no I have it
that's a $10,000 a slice yeah yeah
melted oh god dude I got [ __ ] pulled
a rare [ __ ] I don't have polar bear
paws it I've heard so I've heard it's
good so good cold but ha yeah it's cool
that the [ __ ] clip part yeah yeah
yeah all right what how Joseph good good
did you Clint how's your stuff but the
real is this did you wanna you and I
let's be real did we have a falling out
we never had a falling out yeah but we
were hanging out a lot okay you suffer
from I guess anxiety buddy what do you
suffer from Wow you want to get into my
shed yeah yes be okay every time I'm
around Bobby it's always bite my nail
biting my nail and then he goes crazy
and then he leaves me am i not lying
am I not lying and that's been our
friendship for a long time like when we
were working on the pilot together
what'd you do last time you guys saw
each other yeah he whiteness nails in
the parking lot mama bah you don't
understand Joe you don't understand you
don't yeah
yeah and then he left and then he left
and then as he was fading away you could
still see his ass crack because he yeah
never wears about so you and I didn't
have a I could last conversation you
have with me in that car yeah I forgot
what building were you you really did
inspire me you did kick me in the ass I
was going through a shitty time at that
time yeah so then I understood where's
your Netflix specials killing it and you
know I paid for that and that's
partially due to you what you paid for
your own Netflix special yeah you wait
you independently produced it and then
they bought it yeah they didn't want it
at first then um okay this is how it
went down it was because I shot at 2016
so I was asking them 2015 but I was
already offered my third with Comedy
Central but I wanted Netflix yeah so I
played my card wrong but I guess it was
right yeah cuz since I waited so long
for Netflix Comedy Central was like well
we're good we already got our roster
yeah so at that point they weren't
coming to see me and I was just not
understanding why I'm like yo I'm sold
out two weeks in a row here two weeks in
there oh yeah come see what's going on
here like I deserve a special whatever
and then whatever the case may be they
were busy whatever it was their schedule
has already booked for 2017 and I was
like well [ __ ] what do I do
do I wait till 2018 or do I shoot it
myself and try and get back into you
know shoot it edit it and hand it to him
the right way they don't have to worry
about scheduling or anything and I chose
to do that that's a smarter way to go
you have conditional really but you have
control the way it looks
[Music]